i am not doing your surgery until you
can prove to me
that you're not going to touch a
cigarette for at least the next four
weeks
as of now you're not my patient what do
you mean
i cannot take that risk with you he
wasn't willing to take that risk but
angela was
even after her doctor rejected her for
facelift surgery
she still tried to talk him into doing
it i'm gonna use my southern charm
to see if i can get that faceless
surgery oh goodness
we're gonna talk about it plus why your
mom call me hooker
someone called you hooker i mean no one
called you she sings i'm a hooker
here we go with this one natalie accused
mike's mom of calling her a hooker
and honestly i wouldn't be surprised if
she did
when i was outside trish called me a
hooker
and i don't want to be called that
because i'm a good respect to a woman
i can't with these two they're both out
of line
yet mike sits there like he doesn't see
or hear a thing
hey 90 day fans fam it's melisia
i hope you're well this episode angela
hit
a new roadblock in her attempt to look
younger for michael
after the doctor refused to give her a
facelift
because she won't stop smoking were you
supposed to quit after your last surgery
well what did he say yes she was i know
now we're adults we know that quitting
isn't easy
well i hope we're all adults watching
this we know that quitting isn't easy
there's no shame in that at least you're
trying
but what got me is the fact that after
they denied her over the phone
angela thought she could walk into his
office
and get him to do it anyway well i was
really excited for today to come because
i'm supposed to be getting my faceless
surgery
but dr sadak and that ruben's patient
coordinator natasha told me
you know yesterday that
since i've been smoking that um
the surgery's gonna be off it's a
disappointment but
i don't take no easily
[Music]
i'm on my way to dr doc's office and i'm
gonna use my southern charm
to see if i can get that facelift
surgery angela
we know that you are a strong woman but
i don't know why you thought that was
going to work
if you can charm a doctor into giving
you surgery you need a new doctor
i don't want to have that liability on
my side and on top of all of that
the most important thing your health
angela
what about your health well what do you
say your life is way more valuable than
a pretty face
i know it's easy for us to think we're
invincible at times but
we're not in this particular procedure
face neck lifting
the blood vessels that gives blood
supply oxygen
food to the skin to heal they get choked
so they get very small
and therefore blood doesn't get to that
level and if you're smoking beforehand
it would kill the skin in that part so
we call it tissue necrosis it would just
die which
you know angela is like i don't know
what you're talking about
but it sounds like i'm not gonna get
what i want my southern charm is not
working today she was bold for trying
now lucky for her the doctor is still
willing to do the surgery at a later
time
but it's contingent on these two things
one
when she comes back to him in four weeks
he's going to nicotine test her
i got one for you i'll keep my word and
won't smoke and i'm not
doing a nicotine test then you won't get
a new face
it's as simple as that here's another
level
dr sadat also took things up a level
when he told angela she has to sign a
contract that says she's going to stop
smoking in a contract
the contract stated that she would have
to pay a fine of fifteen hundred dollars
if the doctor cancels the appointment
because she smoked
can i can i just can i can i just oh i'm
already
lord that contract had angela sweating
and stuttering
i can i just oh i'm already
she decided not to sign it for now
because she wants to think about it
first
can i think about this yes again i just
can't sign this one which is totally
understandable
this is a big deal but all of this
really got me thinking
about how so much of our lives and
what's possible for our lives
revolve around tiny habits
i have tried offspring size 13. i hate
them i hate cigarettes
i'm learning personally in my own life
that changing an
old habit it is not for the faint of
heart
it is not it's hard you literally have
to retrain your brain
but it's possible people quit smoking
all the time
so she can do it it just boils down
to how bad she wants to experience the
new
or if she's just cool with settling with
the same old samo
by the way was i the only one looking
hard at these straight to camera shots
trying to see if she ended up getting
the facelift i couldn't tell
and i feel like if she did we would
clearly be able to see
i'm rooting for you angela you got this
anyway next week it looks like she's
going to make the decision
angela it's your last cigarette tell me
about your what are you thinking
i'm thinking that i'm going to enjoy my
last cigarette
alone this is the last one i'm having
i know i got to quit smoking so i
decided to get hypnotized i've tried
everything else in the book
i can do this i'm a tough [ __ ] i can
quit easter rest today
ah there it goes
hey sometimes you just have to jump off
that cliff
even when you're not ready i decided to
get hypnotized
and she's getting hypnotized what i
can't wait to see that
i know with angela and all of this
plastic surgery talk
some of you are probably out there
thinking okay what about michael
where's the focus on her romance with
him he wants a baby
yeah she's spending 25k on the face 25
000 dollars what
yeah come back to the nigerian era
please that's about
11.5 million
although michael's past actions have
rubbed me the wrong way
i will admit that after watching this
episode
my perspective has changed on him a bit
she won't
listen to me angela keeps thinking that
he doesn't care
i've been through hell recovering from
these surgeries and michael don't get
it doesn't seem like that's the case
he's just tired of not feeling hurt in
their marriage
i don't like it at this moment so i just
stopped calling up michael explained
that before he and angela got married
they decided to share their finances but
she hasn't even been consulting him
when it comes to spending all this money
on surgeries i wish my wife
she would at least respect my opinion
sometimes you know make decisions
together not only hers
you know they'll just be as one
couple you know as one one body
you know my is nothing like i thought it
would be
she's making big decisions without me
with the
surgery and now all i and angela do is
fight
five fights at this point i don't know
if i will ever be happy be married to
angela
i think it's so interesting how in
relationships
we can think we're doing something to
keep our partners
in angela's case getting all these
surgeries but in reality
we are really pushing them away
mm-hmm well speaking of pushing away
i hate to say this but i can't wait to
mike and natalie call it quits
i can't these two are stressful to watch
would you rinse that for me please put
it rinse it
this thanksgiving trip to his mom's
house has to be the most
uncomfortable thanksgiving trip ever
you could literally feel the animosity
between natalie and his mom
through the screen and so i don't i
don't need it honey i just wanted to get
the
horse starch out so it wouldn't stick in
there
just put it in the sink
it's incredible
[Laughter]
oh my god on top of trish allegedly
calling natalie a hooker
there were these moments where natalie
would randomly
just start laughing when trish would say
something
which was weird if you pass around the
table essentially
so i do what'd you just say
i don't know if that was her way of
easing the tension in the room
or if she was trying to throw shade
you're pulling my chain i just didn't
get it as we know
natalie has been upset with trish ever
since she tried to call off her wedding
to mike
and trish has been over natalie for a
while now because of the way she treats
her son
so they spend thanksgiving in defense
mode throwing all these little jabs at
one another
i don't have to prove anything to trish
she puts down herself eventually
i think the biggest problem with mike
and natalie's marriage is how natalie
acts in this relationship
she's my child well i think trish could
act a bit more mature in this situation
as well
she's been throwing a lot of shade at
natalie and it's that nice
nasty shade that shade with a little bow
on the end
so where are you at natalie with the
whole baby thing you think that you want
to have some
sooner or later or
you're not sure yet because you're kind
of
getting up there you're getting old you
get you guys are becoming old folks
natalie looks like she wants to go off
and trish
you don't even want her to be married to
your son
why are you acting like you want her to
be the mother of your grandkids
i think uh i don't want my brother
to go through stress and i really want
to be capable to feed my baby
you know you're a single mom was that
supposed to be a jab
you see what i mean you know you're a
single mom
it was a bunch of that going on and mike
just let him do it i know that these are
the two most important women in his life
and it might be scary to say something
but
he needs to find the words i think it's
just a misunderstanding
thankfully it looks like next week he
will natalie i don't know what i said or
did about
what hurts your feelings trish i don't
understand
these jokes you make towards me what was
disrespectful
answer the question what did just live
hey natalie
mike and natalie's marriage i think it's
something that's not gonna work in the
end
give her five thousand dollars and send
her back to frank
oh she says send her back it's about
that time
all right 90 day fans fam you never know
what's gonna happen with those two
so to make sure you stay updated on all
the latest news coming out the 90 day
universe
make sure you stick with et because we
are covering it all i will see you next
[Music]
time
you